Hello, I'm Rajiv. I'm a practicing
medical doctor here in London
and been doing some AI engineering for
the past few years. Particularly
interested in real world application and
really the future which is multi-agent
multi-human multi-institutional
collaboration through a company called
Anitcha Labs.
And really the premise of my talk today
is to introduce a new design philosophy
for the future of AI engineering which
is beyond a harness or beyond a fixed
static harness and towards adaptive
engineering.
This slide basically summarizes my
entire talk
and really it's about exploring what the
current AI engineering paradigm is which
is to use fixed harnesses
to steer agents. So we either use or
build an existing harness like Pi,
Claude, Code, Cursor, CodeX, whatever it
is ahead of run time that remains fairly
consistent throughout the engineering
process and is largely constrained with
fixed roles and tools and sequencing
which again ahead of the process
beginning of the process we can tweak
and it essentially produces very
reliable and orderly work and it's great
for most engineering problems and ideas.
And so your role as an AI engineering
right now is to use a harness and steer
agents.
But the future's going to be different
in at least two ways.
Number one, models are going to become
so powerful that existing fixed
harnesses are constantly going to become
outdated.
And number two is there's going to be a
huge exposure to the real world. Right
now a lot of AI engineering is software
based. It's within behind a screen.
But actually, as things get more
powerful, as models get more powerful,
we're going to have exposure to the real
world where
I'd argue that this is where the real
challenges are.
And the real world is dynamic and messy.
You know, it's full of multi-agent,
multi-human, cross-institutional,
and really touching the physical world,
which means that a fixed harness is
quite brittle.
And so that's where we enter what I coin
as adaptive engineering, where you
actually allow the harness to emerge and
adapt mid-engineering
to find its most optimal position and
structure.
And essentially, the engineer's role is
going to be to design some of the
constraints, which are kind of the rules
of play,
and really allowing the harness
to emerge, stabilize, change, and
eventually dissolve
as you go through the runtime of
engineering.
So, let's look firstly at the current
paradigm for AI engineering. And it's
essentially
where a harness
serves as the primary method to guide an
LLM, which is typically stateless,
and make it into something quite useful.
And there's a couple of aspects of a
harness, which I won't go to in detail,
but essentially things like system
prompts, which is established by the
harness vendor,
meaning that users can't actually modify
it. And this essentially
tells the harness what it can and can't
do.
You've also got the agents.md files or
the Claude.md if you're using Claude
code, which is loaded into every context
window at the start of a session,
tool calling,
and essentially then you have the
genesis of agents, which are specialized
entities that have been harnessed uh,
granting them unique capabilities
um, and and allowing them to
differentiate from other agents. And
these capabilities are typically
manifest as specific skills when it
comes to role typology, their
capabilities, the rules um, and that
enables them to deliver targeted outputs
and specified outputs, whether it be
code
documentation
issues, handoffs and and most recently
we've seen the genesis of kind of loops,
loop engineering has become a thing um
so that eventually we reach some sort of
outcome
uh, whether it's a feature,
uh, a problem solved which is eventually
reviewed by a human. Um, so what you see
uh, from this is that before running the
engineering process
the entire harness has been
predetermined or pre-engineered. And
that's harness engineering. And uh, it's
been remarkable
at getting the most out of the latest
models.
Um and just sort of stepping a bit back,
um, defining exactly what a harness is.
Essentially the model is the engine and
the harness is everything built around
to make that engine useful. Um, there's
many different types of harnesses. I
mean, there's hundreds uh, actually, but
I guess the most common ones are,
um, you know, CLI coding, um, such as
Claude Code, Codex, Pi. You have IDEs
like Cursor uh, multi-agent
orchestration through LangChain
and and things like Hermes as well,
Klein and Goose. And And these are all
differentiated based on number one,
properties and how they're configured.
But actually more importantly,
number two,
based on some sort of design and
engineering philosophy that they believe
in. And what makes them so great and so
distinct is that they are opinionated to
a lesser or greater degree. Um and they
allow for, I guess different use cases.
Um and depending on your temperament as
an engineer, you'd pick one over the
other.
But what we do see in all of these is
that everything's predefined. You know,
you can customize them, of course, like
for example, the Pi agent. It's
minimalist and it's maximally
extensible. Um
but everything is predefined. You know,
the roles, fixed outputs, sequencing
protocols, how memory is created. Uh and
so I want to be absolutely clear here. I
don't mean that you can't customize
harnesses. Of course, you can. But the
customization occurs ahead of the
engineering runtime. Uh and not
mid-engineering. And that's largely
directed by us as humans. And for
someone like me who started AI
engineering about two years ago,
it's probably the most powerful or
predictive uh predictable method.
And it's got really three payoffs. It's
reliable.
Um you know, the same input leads to a
similar set of outputs. Obviously,
there's going to be some variation.
It's auditable. Um you can inspect
exactly what changed and when. And
there's some sort of linear causality
where
uh you know, if something breaks, you
can actually trace it back to its
source.
Um
this is like a factory line though. Like
think Taylorism for AI. Just like a
factory assembly line, every station is
engineered in advance. Um, each agent
has one job, a fixed place, a sequence,
and maybe a defined handoff to the next
agent.
I mean, there's clearly some incredible
uses for this and, you know, factory
engineering gives you, you know,
accuracy, speed, reproducibility,
behavior that you can certify, and it
really shines in these kind of closed
deterministic systems, where you have a
well-defined product or problem, and you
know the kind of features you want to
build. You know the sort of solutions
that you need. Um,
but here's the catch. Um, and and it's a
real trade-off that that reliability
isn't free. Um, you buy it by
suppressing, um,
variance that I'd argue novelty
requires.
Um, and determinism and emergence pull
kind of in opposite directions.
Um, and
this is where we have to pivot to the
real world, because in real life
situations, in when when AI eventually,
uh,
when it becomes a norm for AI to capture
real-world scenarios, where you've got
multi-agents, multi-humans,
multi-institutions interacting, and also
touching the physical world,
um,
there's a hard ceiling on novelty, um,
because the real world is messy, and it
keeps changing. And so, fixed harness
starts to break down. Um, so like I
mentioned, there's a hard ceiling on
novelty, um,
because,
uh, essentially, its reliability is
predicated on suppressing
variants. Um the models are going to
keep accelerating.
You know, you can build a careful
harness today or you can use one off the
shelf.
But it could be irrelevant in the next
month. The model just got so good that
it didn't need that kind of scaffolding
anymore.
Um and that kind of leads to this whole
dilemma of brutalness where every
situation you didn't anticipated
you didn't anticipate needs a human to
patch the harness.
The more real world it needs, the more
rules you bolt on and eventually the
harness just becomes ever more
complicated than the actual problem that
you need to solve.
And I guess if there's one takeaway here
is that the factory method
is the right answer to a fixed problem
and the wrong answer to a moving
problem.
And so let's really examine in what the
real world is about and and I'm going to
go down a bit of a philosophical route
here.
Um
as we've said,
you know, agentic systems will
eventually collide with the real world
and that raises a question.
What is the real world actually made of?
Because there's two ways to answer this
actually. So the first paradigm, the
first way to see the world is through
what we call a reductionist or
analytical view
which we're all very used to actually.
It says to understand the whole
a big problem or a system or a big thing
like an organization
we've got to take it apart and study the
individual parts. So essentially the
world is made up of these individual
parts which are things that are stable
and change is just something that
happens to those stable things now and
then.
The relationships amongst those things
are secondary or an afterthought.
And this is really the metaphysics of a
factory
and of nearly all software that we
build. You know, you make the
components.
Uh
you wire them together.
And you get a product.
The second paradigm, what we call the
systems or relational paradigm,
um takes the emphasis away from there
being separate things or components
and actually puts more what we call
ontological
emphasis on the relationships amongst
those things. So, flips the order. It
says that the real world isn't made up
of things at all.
It's made up of processes and um
relationships which come first.
So, what we call a stable thing really
is just a slow pattern in an ongoing
flow. Think an organism. It's more like
a flame than a crystal. A flame looks
like an object, but it isn't. It's a
pattern held together moment by moment
by a process. You stop the process and
the thing doesn't exist.
Uh and there's a really
good payoff in understanding this
paradigm. Um and once you see the world
in this way, you start to notice
something remarkable. Where where you
have simple local rules between, let's
say,
particles or between people or between
creatures,
that local interaction gives rise to a
whole new level
of order that can't be predicted from
its constituent parts and that no
constituent part designed ahead of time.
For example, water. Water has a property
of being wet.
But it's
constituent parts, oxygen and hydrogen,
are not wet.
But their coming together, again putting
emphasis on the relationships,
their coming together is where you had
the emergence of a novel new property,
i.e. wetness.
Another example is a flock of birds. Not
one bird wakes up every morning
intending to make a flock.
Each probably just follows three simple
local rules, which is align with your
neighbor, don't crash into them,
stay close, and that's it. Local rules,
local interactions, and out of that you
get a flock,
a new pattern alive and coordinated that
you could never understand by pulling it
apart and studying one bird because no
single bird has a flock in it. The flock
lives in the relationships, not the
parts.
So this factory method of engineering
assumes a world of parts.
But the non-machine world, and I'd argue
that AI is sort of on the cusp of that,
the non-machine world is a world of
patterns and moving patterns of
emergence.
And that sort of reflects what sort of
problems we face in this moving messy
world. Um and there's a line from
Russell Ackoff that I absolutely love.
He says that managers aren't handed neat
separate problems.
They're handed dynamic situations,
tangles of problems that keep changing
and keep bumping to each other. And he
And he gave that a name. He called it a
mess. A mess is a isn't just a pile of
separate parts, it's actually a system
of relationships in motion.
Which is exactly why the factory based
on a fixed harness
way of engineering will struggle when it
collides with real-world live scenarios.
Because you can't decompose a mess into
tidy boxes and solve each of them
because they're not individual parts,
they're a moving pattern of
relationships.
We can then look at problems through
this
this distinction between different types
of problems. So,
um engineering is all about solving
problems and I'd argue that very simply
put there are two kinds of problems.
There are complicated problems
um
and there are complex problems. So, a
complicated system or complicated
problem
is like building a jumbo jet or a clock.
There are passive parts
um but experts can take them apart,
analyze them, plan, predict, document.
It's hard, but it's actually knowable
and it works in a very predictable way.
In contrast, when you have a complex
system or a complex problem like a flock
of birds, a market, a human
organization,
it's slightly different. It's parts are
constantly interacting and adapting to
one another. So, the whole
can't be derived
from analyzing the parts. So, you don't
analyze and plan a complex system.
Instead, you probe and sense and respond
and
this is probably one of the most
expensive mistakes we make in the modern
world of design and engineering,
which is that we treat a complex problem
like a complicated one
um and and things fail not due to lack
of execution, but essentially because
there's a failure in categorizing the
problem spaces.
If we go
just one step deeper into what a complex
system is,
um essentially, you know, the
ingredients of it are first, you need a
diverse set of agents or actors if it's
a human organization.
Um not clones essentially, but different
from one another in some sort of way.
So, because the diversity is the fuel
there.
Um they need to interact locally uh cuz
no agent, no individual actor, no
individual component sees the whole. Um
instead each respond to whoever's next
to it. And this is like the bird
aligning with the neighbor.
And they learn. They learn recursively.
They adapt, then they adapt to the
results of their own adapting, and it
constantly loops, and
um
you know, with respect to one another
and the environment.
Everything is moving in response to
everything else, and nothing holds
still. And out of all of that local
adaptive looping interaction,
you get something called emergence,
which is a key
concept in complexity science.
Um basically, it's a new novel pattern
uh or organization or behavior
that uh no single part designed on its
own and can't be explained
by splitting that whole into its parts
and studying them. Again, think the
flock of birds. No bird has a flock in
it. Think about the wetness of water.
None of the individual oxygen hydrogen
molecules have wetness within them. And
yet, it leads to the emergence of
something quite novel.
Now, these systems don't fly apart into
chaos.
They tend to settle into attractors,
which are essentially stable states.
Uh
they keep pulling back towards some sort
of equilibrium. So, for example, water
is stable at room temperature.
So, you get this sort of beautiful
tension. You've got constant change at a
local level,
but then you've got recognizable stable
patterns at a whole system level.
And crucially, nobody's steering here.
It's self-organizing. And that's the
whole mystery. And I'd argue that's the
whole opportunity
for design and engineering. And this is
where
really want to introduce this new design
and engineering philosophy called
adaptive engineering.
Before that, let's just take stock a
bit. So, everything we covered so far
lives inside a particular framework,
which is this kind of fixed or factory
harness. Uh the human engineer decides
it all up front, the sequencing, the
roles, capabilities.
That's really the factory model, and it
works. Um and we've seen that um because
problem spaces that are complicated yet
predictable
is exactly right. And I'd argue for most
engineering problems, that is the
perfect method.
But the moment AI becomes exponentially
better,
and it collides with the real world,
which is, as we found, messy and
complex, not just complicated,
we need something genuinely new, a
different idea of what optimal design
and engineering even is. Um
And it's obviously it rests on those two
assumptions that models have become
become exponentially better.
Uh and that AI will
uh come outside of a sandbox situation,
and actually um engineering will run in
real time in contact with the social and
physical environment. Um so, essentially
what we're saying is that the harness
must adapt mid-flow. And that's the crux
of harness engineering. And
I guess if I were to crystallize
um the definition, um
adaptive engineering is the discipline
of designing constraints
to the extent that the harness emerges
on its own, stabilizes,
and adapts as needed in response to the
changing environment in ways that you
could not specify in advance.
Essentially, the harness becomes the
ongoing output rather than the input.
And
you know, what this means in practice,
uh just to make it a bit more concrete,
is
given that agents have capabilities um
to interact with each other,
organization emerges from those
interactions in response to the
environment or a goal,
such that new levels of order appear,
ones that you could never have specified
up front.
Um so, think bird in a flock, think
agent and harness. So, the agents are
actually creating the harness
in the same way as the birds are
relating to one another so that the
flock can emerge. So, you don't build
the harness anymore. You let the agents
form the harness that best fits the
environment in that moment, in that
context.
>> [snorts]
>> The harness then becomes a
self-organizing,
constantly evolving multi-agent system.
And if we're to just simulate what it
may become, because this is when agents
become a lot more capable. Um
essentially, you have agents that are
isomorphic um but yet undifferentiated.
Um but fully capable of interacting and
um learning and changing.
Um you let those agents interact. At
first, there's nothing. It's a bit of
few exchanges here and there.
But the coupling continues and slowly
builds until you reach a point where
roughly one connection on average um
occurs um
with each agent. And suddenly, you start
to see this whole emerge.
>> [snorts]
>> Um a system, you could say. Uh and I
guess as an engineer, your new lever
uh becomes
uh how the rate of coupling. Like, do
you dial it up or do you
dampen it down? Um again, the adaptive
path focuses on the interactions.
Um until, you know, agents start to
actually specialize with respect to one
another.
So, let's say you got two agents doing
the same thing in the same place. That's
just redundant and the environment knows
that. The pressure from the environment
knows that. So, it rewards anything that
essentially breaks the tie. Um
so
I guess a tiny difference um
you know, who got there first, who is
slightly better
gets amplified by the feedback until
those two agents are no longer
interchangeable. And so, the pool stops
becoming something uniform and it
actually falls into uh niches. And
really, the key insight here is that the
agent's identity isn't something you
gave it.
It's actually the position, role, or
capability it took relative to the
others and its environment. So, here we
see specialization
emerges from the interaction.
And if you go on a bit further, uh they
stop connecting at random. Uh in fact,
they start to work well together
um, in terms of sort of clusters. Um,
and you see the first boundaries appear
and crucially the system
drew them, you didn't as an engineer
ahead of time. Um, so these are kind of
emergent clusters.
Um, until a new convention crystallizes,
you know, a division of norms and
protocols, and the system produce some
level of governance without a governor.
Conventions emerge spontaneously from
the local coordination
with no central authority because as
we've seen, central authority can lead
to brittleness in a changing
environment.
Um, so there's just enough repeated
interaction to tip the group into some
sort of shared norm. And this is crucial
really because it means that it can
continue to adapt in a decentralized way
based on the changing environment or
problem space.
And essentially a new um,
emergent order um, arises from those
tiny little interactions amongst those
agents, you have a new level of
organization that is fairly stable up
until the next iteration, up until the
environment changes
and um, the order needs to essentially
restructure itself.
So the question is that what is the role
of an engineer? And and really in
adaptive engineering, uh, you don't
abolish the engineer, you're just
relocating the emphasis of engineering.
So if you can exploit the model's
capabilities, um, so agents can
essentially
um, interact, learn, and change. What
you're doing as an engineer is
essentially um,
exploring the constraints, you're
dictating the constraints, the rules of
the game. You're not deciding what
should happen or what you want to
happen, but you're giving the agent
space to explore that field.
>> [clears throat]
>> And then, once that emergent harness
uh
starts to take shape, you are sensing it
and responding to that rather than um
stopping the engineering process and
starting from scratch.
Um
And I think this slide sort of um
portrays that. This is not
binary, this is not either or. Uh in
fact, it's very much a continuum.
Um if you you there's no purely fixed
harness way, and there's no purely
uh completely adaptive autonomous way.
Um
fixed engineering is essentially in one
hand um prescribing the structure, which
agents run and you rarely change the
structure mid-engineering.
Um whereas on the other end of the
scale, you've got adaptive engineering
where you allow the agents to freely
interact and allow the harness or the
structure that guides them
uh to be created by them and change
mid-engineering.
Uh so it's not like a swarm of agents
loose with no roles and this sort of
intelligence that magically appears.
Um and it's not sort of better one one
way is not better than the other. They
just have two different use cases. And
um if I could just, you know, bring it
back to some examples of existing uh
harnesses, so for example, Hermes AI um
on on their website, it states that it's
a self-improving AI agent that creates
skills from experience and learns from
it. So, obviously, this is a huge step
in terms of adaptive direction. Um but I
do want to make a distinction here um
because um that adaptation is in the
form of vertical intelligence, which is
about making individual agents smarter.
What I'm talking about here is
horizontal intelligence, which is all
about how groups
of agents coordinate. And so, those two
directions are a bit orthogonal. Um
And the thesis I'm presenting is that
it's horizontal intelligence uh that is
the most adaptive method, the most agile
method. Um and and and arguably the
higher leverage point.
Uh compared to vertical.
Um
Another example is Pi, um
you know, a great harness, uh which is
uh
sort of essentially minimal, um yet it's
maximally extensible. Um so, it's fully
customizable to an extent. Um so, you
could class that as adaptive, but again,
there's a distinction here. There's
adaptive at the design stage, like when
you're preparing for that engineering
process. Um
Uh
where the engineer can customize and the
tool's quite malleable.
But, when it comes to adaptive
engineering, that's all about being
adaptive during the run time, where the
system reorganizes itself whilst running
in response to the changing problem
space of the environment. And you know,
Pi is a strong example of the first
kind,
um but it doesn't make any claims um to
be anything other. Uh it's not a
self-organizing multi-agent system yet.
I'm just going to skip over some of the
uh nitty-gritties of what that could
mean. Um so, for example,
um
uh when it comes to agent capabilities,
you know, obviously, they need to
interact, learn, and change. That's kind
of a prerequisite
for adaptive engineering and I don't
doubt that that will
become the case as models get
exponentially more powerful.
There's a few things that the designer
can actually do in the form of
constraints and I'm not going to list
out all the different types of
constraints cuz they're sort of largely
dictated by some of the properties like
the roles and the sequencing and the
memory. These are all sort of categories
or properties of harness.
But essentially there are three
questions that you could ask yourself as
an engineer which is
do you want to
enable
the agents more or do you want to close
them in and govern them more
and produce more
give them more guardrails.
Are you rewarding them to cohere towards
a particular goal or are you costing
them
if they fall outside a particular
container?
And how fast or slow do you want this um
to happen? Some of the properties, you
know, what's the speed for example the
rate of coupling. So these are some of
the engineering tweaks that you can make
when it comes to adaptive engineering.
And then finally like this emergent
harness that is constantly shaping and
reshaping itself based on the problem
space.
You can only really sense and respond to
that emergent harness. You're not going
to
completely
be able to
I guess
edit
it in some sort of hard engineering
fashion cuz that's not in the best
interest of you as an adaptive engineer.
This slide is just a more detailed
comparison of both approaches and again
I want to emphasize that one is not
better than the other. It's just two
different design engineering
philosophies.
Where on one hand in the factory model,
um you know, the structure is imposed up
front by the engineer, and so the
harness becomes the input. Um whereas in
the adaptive path, the harness emerges
and is essentially the output. Um
And And one of the crucial things here
is that control is decentralized
in the [clears throat] adaptive path.
Um in the field continuously
um because the problem space eventually
when AI um comes or AI engineering comes
off a screen into the real world, um the
problem space is constantly changing. Um
Now, it's important to understand that,
you know, there are particular use cases
for this. Um but there are a huge number
of failure modes um in this as well. Um
you know, just to list a few of those
failure modes, you know, emergence leans
towards uh stability, what we call an
attractor, uh where you find a structure
that feels stable and optimal, but that
doesn't necessarily mean it's the best.
Um
you need some sort of genuine selection
pressure. So, if you imagine in the
social world or the physical or the
natural world, the environment is um
giving us certain uh pressures. You
know, that's what encourages us to
adapt. That is evolution. You know,
there is some sort of selection pressure
here.
And you kind of need to find that um
in or we as a community need to find
that in adaptive engineering, otherwise
you just get drift.
There is a risk of monoculture, where
you don't get genuine diversity amongst
agents because they're all trained on
the same data.
Um legibility does collapse. Um you
know, you as adaptability increases,
um
you can't really pin down or explain
things that well. And again, that's a
feature of complex systems. You can't
really pin them down.
And and and obviously goes without
saying that there's no more
predictability ahead of runtime because
things are constantly moving.
Um
And and and these are the real failure
modes that we must apprehend because I
do feel like adaptive engineering is
something that we're going to be more
inclined towards and it's going to race
forward um from the future.
>> [clears throat and cough]
>> I guess a bit of a takeaway then.
Um you know, as models improve
exponentially
um
AI engineering will move into the real
world scenarios.
You know, the real world where it
touches um the physical space
uh on an ongoing basis. It's uh in
contact with multiple agents across
different institutions. It's in contact
with multiple human beings. So
So there's a real cost peer where AI is
heading towards. And so the discipline
of design and engineering is going to be
forced to rethink itself around
continual production.
>> [snorts]
>> And the limiting factor which is the
case now, but probably more so in the
future, is not going to be the strength
of the model.
It's going to be the adaptability of the
harness. Um and adaptability really here
means multi-agent
um
which is essentially about coordinating
amongst agents. A multi-agent
orchestration
which is decentralized.
Um and it's not
adaptable ahead of runtime.
In fact, it starts becoming adaptable
mid run-time or during an entire
engineering a process. And I think
that's real intelligence. That's Well,
when I say real intelligence, I mean
that's the intelligence when it comes to
adaptability of the harness.
Uh,
I'd be really interested in um hearing
your thoughts on this um
and whether this is something that uh
other people are also exploring. Um
please do reach out to me.
Thank you.